how does the state of this game relate
to cancel culture
well i mean it's very very very much so
i mean i mean you know
into the internet mobs i think are um
a dominance virtue game it's about
threat it's about coercion it's about
you will follow the rules of my status
game also virtue signaling on the side
of the of this canceler as well
absolutely yeah
and and and yeah i i think one of the i
think probably the the most interesting
thing the the the idea that really made
sense of cancer culture for me was this
idea called the tyranny of the cousins
um and the the chapter about internet
mobs is called the tyranny of the
cousins and this was a real surprise to
me so so is this the idea that the
groups in which we evolved very often
not always but very often didn't have
like a big leader big man leader at the
top who was in charge and you know that
was really surprising to me because when
you look at human life today there's
leaders everywhere you know we seem to
love leaders but but they weren't and
and so there was no sort of big single
leader that was in charge of everything
instead there would be sort of a group
of you know elders or kind of high
status
there were relatively egalitarian groups
relatively high status people that would
gather together to make decisions at
certain times um and you know
according to their specialism you know
different people might have you know
different kinds of sway but it's very
much about um
you know the these early human groups
these pre-modern groups are very much
about consensus or the illusion of
consensus and and so that happens when
people break breaks the rules of the
group you know it wasn't like somebody
would decide you're going to be punished
it was just this sense of consensus
would gather against this person and it
would be an atmosphere of of gossip
people telling nasty stories about him
um and and and that would that would
create moral outrage and more moral
outrage would create more consensus and
it would build up and build up and build
up until you know and in the case in
which i described in the book this poor
bastard was accused of um using sorcery
to kill somebody and he was killed and
eaten
yeah and
and so that's exactly what you see you
know that is exactly what you see on
social media no one's in charge of a
council culture mob no one can start it
no one can stop it it's something that
that builds itself up in an atmosphere
of accusation gossip and consensus and
it just and and it kind of fires at this
person and so so you know the the the
tyranny of the cousins is about this
idea that
you know when we were evolving in those
groups um
we weren't under the kind of fear of the
tyranny of leaders where it was the fear
of the tyranny of these cousins and
there weren't literal cousins but there
were these ideas of these closely
you know the the these these tribal
elders that would sort of
lead and sort of whisper to each other
and and and try and make this consensus
happen and you know it's extraordinary i
could compare kind of a modern mobbing
to a
a deadly mobbing and i think it was the
kabusi tribe in papua new guinea and and
some of the details are
hauntingly um similar in in in what
happens in in these incidents you know
the victims
in a state of panic um when they realize
what's happening
you know dancing between conf you know
defending themselves not being too
scared to defend themselves and then
semi-confessing but they're not because
they didn't actually bloody do anything
and you know you see this in the gabusi
and you see this in you know victims of
cancer culture
you also looked at the first ever social
media network thing
from the internet ages ago and there was
echoes of exactly what we're seeing now
there and it's just a reminder that
perhaps technology's removed the
friction and it's made it more expedited
that we can do this it's quicker and
it's more aggressive and there's more
fragmented groups in groups and out
groups that are playing status games
against each other because of that
frictionlessness but it's nothing new
you know to blame and this was something
that was a tough pill for me to swallow
because i think that human nature i like
to think that human nature is
fundamentally virtuous and good and it's
an easy out to blame the ills that we're
seeing at the moment on
algorithms and and social media but
they may magnify but
the the fundamental of where these
impulses came from
is our nature right yeah absolutely and
this was a big lesson i learned again
when i was researching selfie and that
was all about you know
the the kind of the narcissism of social
media and where that came from and one
of the big sort of turning points of
understanding for me and there was the
idea of the selfie camera and you know
the the the the idea
was that you know um
the the the technologist is steve jobs
fault and it's you know google's fault
for for selfie culture because they put
these cameras on the phones but you know
the original selfie cameras weren't
called selfie cameras they were called
front-facing cameras and and what apple
and the other companies thought they'd
be good for were business meetings and
for talking to your nan but that's not
what we did with them you know we
started taking pictures of ourselves you
know mostly um so so you know you know
silicon valley are constantly throwing
ideas at us the you know 99.99 of those
ideas get rejected and a tiny mountain
get get picked up and it's the people
it's human beings that decide which
silicon valley technologies are
successful and those and those companies
then you know
tune their platforms and devices around
what we want and you know what i found
in selfies exactly the same as what i
found when i was researching the status
game and social media
it's that you can't blame mark
zuckerberg or jack dorsey for um cancel
culture um
yeah the the first kind of social media
site and as we would recognize it today
was was the well um it which was back in
the you know form back in the 1980s
still when people were having to do that
thing with their phones like off war
games i don't know what it is a modem so
so it was a very small group and
when it got to about
about 500 users so the world was a bit
like reddit so the idea was like um
uh people it was mostly people in in
california
they would gather around little interest
groups and they just play little status
games talking about you know wine or the
you know eco stuff or whatever it was
and when it when it got to about um 500
this sort of this individual arrived who
just basically hated men and was just
you know firing off all this anti-male
invective constantly and you know and
and and they kind of mobbed around this
person they got them kicked off the
platform eventually deleted as many of
their this person's um
um uh
entries
as possible yeah so so it was all there
and this person was gender
non-conformist so
biologically female didn't identify as
man but but used male pronouns and used
male name so um slightly complicated but
i just thought it was extraordinary that
in 1986
there was council culture they were
arguing about pronouns you know all the
stuff that we see today and that we you
know we tend to we often blame on mark
zuckerberg or jack dorsey happened in
the very first social media website and
to me that just shows you know what is
twitter it's status games you bring
people together you connect them into
communities they start competing for
status and you know with each other and
against you know game versus game and
that's what that and so and you know and
when that started working for twitter of
course they they molded their technology
around these things but they didn't
create it
it was inevitably what was going to
happen you know
yeah quite this is this you know one of
the other things i wrote about and
selfie and also in this book is this
kind of utopian technologist idea the
wired you know magazine ideas from the
90s and the early 2000s the vision of
the internet which is when you connect
everybody together it's going to be this
utopia no hierarchy no disagreement
everybody getting on together and it's
just the opposite of what happened and
it's the opposite of what happened
because it's human nature you know
that's what we do you know for good and
for ill that's what we do
as individuals
is it is it low status behavior to talk
openly
about
status like is acknowledging status
motives a low status signal
yeah that's a really weird one it
obviously is you know people
people don't like to think um
uh of themselves as as only only do this
for status it's a terrible you know we
we readily recognize it in our enemies
but but we we hate recognizing it in
ourselves and you know
and i think you know there's
it's really this idea of the story's
heading brain you know if the
subconscious truth of us is we're just
all out going for connection and status
as well as those other drives you know
sex food you know all the other stuff
enabled by status yeah the the um or
yeah well yeah
yes
and um
the the kind of conscious experience of
life we have isn't that we tell this
heroic story about ourselves
and
you know so so
in several books i've talked about the
idea of the brain as the hero maker it
takes all the messy realities of our
day-to-day life and conjures this heroic
story of self um uh uh that explains who
we are in the best possible light and
you know and increasingly the way i've
come to see that kind of story is it's
almost like a sales pitch to both to to
to the people with whom you share your
life you know you really believe it's
true um you've got all these biases and
prejudices which which distort reality
you know we even misremember our past in
such a way that makes us feel more
heroic um so so so i i think it's that
kind of sales pitch that story that that
is actually the conscious experience is
so resistant to this idea of status
because he doesn't want to think of
ourselves as that it's a hero maker he
wants to say no i want to change the
world i want to i'm just i'm a good
person i am
i am better than everybody else it's not
you know
so um so so yeah i think i think that's
why there's this disconnect you know
it's this it's this
it's this unpleasant subconscious truth
i think in a way
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace